das kann ja dauernd schlecht einschätzen
ich habe gerade gesagt wenn ich noch ein
auto anfährt bin ich tot und ich liege
auf dem boden und sein auto berührt mich
einfach nur mit den reifen gestorben
ich habe im flieger und keiner schießt
auf mich wo ich bin der barbie da hinten
die hoch glaube nicht dass ich glaube
ich kann jetzt springen ja ich bringe
mal
ich glaube ich bin gar nicht mehr so
weit
das aber bleibt bleibt oben auf dem berg
ich komme der gondel hoch aber ich bin
ja nicht mal ganz oben
ich habe gerade gesagt wenn ich noch ein
auto anfährt bin ich tot und ich liege
auf dem boot und sein auto berührt mich
einfach nur mit den reifen wenn ich mir
einfach nicht glauben aber ich glaube
jetzt zu dieser im gondel horst hin und
dann kommt nach oben und dann können wir
weiter machen dann laufen wir zusammen
wie willst du jetzt nach unten kommt ich
bin zum zug
bei den schienen dann kläre ich mein
auto funktioniert ja das nein ich hoffe
das hier ist ja nirgends ohne auto das
ist ja die kacke hier ist hat hat junge
tatsache hier ist irgendwo ein auto kann
ich irgendwie waffen wechseln
aber jetzt habe ich dir jetzt habe ich
die hälftige waffe hier sollen übersehen
waren tagen erst haben so schön bleibt
stehen keiner bleibt still im
multiplayer wenn man doch okay du wirst
mich bereit meine karre mit der ich
jetzt ankomme weil ich weiß nicht aber
okay ich komme zu dir
man kann es einfach weg das fa die pont
dies bolt lief wo bist du okay ich sehe
in hessen
du verwechselst du bist aber ja doch zu
cocoa ja da kommst du irgendein buggy
tisch und biologie so grätz wettmachen
am anfang ein paar mal auf dem berg oder
wäre rumfahren sind jetzt in acht euro
pro jahr
aber das handling die karre wir können
sie aber keine bitte zusammen klären
oder aber nicht mehr jugend für
langweiler ganze ganzen dein geld in die
luft werfen
du kannst auch eine mit dem
freibadgelände die sympathie wenn die
sagen wenn die sympathiewelle
skandalöser 2 mitnehmen
das alles schon aus gerecht zwei
gleichzeitig mit den karten spielen
karten spielen auch manchmal kuno und
mensch ärgere dich nicht
aber aber nicht replay sudoku de das
weiß ich nicht das recht gibt es wäre
aber nicht mehr jugendfrei für youtube
was ist denn wenn man mehr als 30 wieder
richtig viele wichtige arbeitet das
schon okay ja wir könnten auch ein jet
ski rennen machen würde jetzt gießen wo
wollen wir jetzt am strand letztmalig
punkt oder sehe ich da überhaupt mache
einfach da unternehmen wie 70 ich gucke
immer das militär basis wollen wir die
militärbasis reingehen gott gebe aus -
komm schnell schießt den wegpunkt ja
sich aus mühlhausen alter bist du noch
im auto ja du bist gerade einfach auf
locker easy in die militärbasis reingeht
jump ja normal bist du drin natürlich
flugzeug okay manchmal kam mit 12 15
du musst du halt auf 1 holen so steinig
hatte steine es gerecht ist flugzeug ich
dir aus das schaffst du niemals wir
müssen man muss ich direkt daneben
parken in irgendwelchen trick gab es
aber noch beim fliegen dass man hoch
kommt das war das mal dann hochkriecht
ohne den trick weil es gleichen jahr
grad
ja ja nein ich wohl zur über jungen
flieger fliegt ein leben ich bin dir
keine flieger mehr
wunderschön ich bin kein star holt mich
dann gleich abgestürzt ich werde auch
noch an geballert dh ich finde hier
keine flieger mehr ich fahre seit jahren
herum in der medizin
ich hätte mehr herausspringen soll ich
noch ein vollständiger ich fahre hier
eine runde in der militärbasis
ich bin zwar gestorben aber die zeit im
flieger wasche ich finde kein flieger
hatte ich da raus ich hol dich da raus
ich glaube ich schon selbst
rausgesprungen gefahr paar runden
gedreht hat wieder gehalten
doch nicht noch nicht doch nicht doch
nicht doch nicht ich habe noch gar nicht
an die scheiß müssen ist dass tricky
alter doch jetzt bin ich draußen
die machen wir sogar das tor ja nein ich
bin noch bei diesen komischen soll
standen gerade wenig zeit mir dich auf
den markt
doch da war einfach geradeaus ich glaub
jetzt steigen gleich aus dem fall
solltest du dir sterben sie ist dass du
hier
ich habe beim 500er bass dinge aber ich
kann hier nicht raus denn die war dass
ich rausgehe ich kann ja gar nicht ich
habe ja nie irgendwas getan außer
vielleicht im zaun
okay erzählt ich hab zwar vielleicht
nicht raus das sperrgebiet bitte geht
ich bin doch schon drin
bitte geh nicht ins sperrgebiet rhein in
dem wir nicht vertrieben
aber das kann ich hoffe der der figur
wenn der flieger wieder da ist den du
wege schafft es nicht schafft jetzt rein
nein das geht nicht
das geht nicht vor der sogar wenn der
flieger wieder selbst das sperrgebiet zu
hier das ist soll im single player kommt
einfach durch platziert dass ich wieder
da
wir haben singleplayer du das
multiplayer hier warte mal vielleicht
könnt ihr durch die hintertür auf die
auf die linke tour verstehe das nicht
ganze flieger sind weg als ob die nur
ein flieger hatten waren das finden wir
die der basis ihr das schon helikopter
wegen mir ich muss hier auch wiederum
da ist nix du musst dir ein jump
ja das geht glaube nicht also mit meinem
auto wurde hier zunächst mal nichts was
machst du denn ich sehe nur rote punkte
auf der karte aber ich komme ja auch
nicht raus ich muss mich glaube ich
umbringen lassen einfach dass ich bin
gerade zu fuß unterwegs zu fuß auf eine
gute idee ich habe fliege ich sehe euch
denn vielleicht ist ja ich sehe flieger
mein gott alter lauf um dein leben okay
okay okay ich bin ich bin denn ich bin
drin
drinnen bin ich schon mal und ich sehe
auch kein gegner der nie so richtig in
meiner nähe ist
oh mein gott wenn ich schaffe den
flieger zion damit ich bei eltern der
zweiten oder dritten folge der liga sind
gt r
ich habe im flieger und keiner schießt
auf mich wo ich bin der barbie aber sie
hat keine auf mich geschossen eine
rakete meinen popo rein direct.de beste
war richtig enttäuschend
richtig gefragt war schöner als
weihnachten und geburtstag zusammen wo
bist du denn ich bin außerhalb dieser
militärbasis
ich war rechtlich bring ich um bringst
dich um und zahlt dafür sogar 500 mut
hat den leichtesten ausweg gewählt
hier liegt ein kaputter job das ist
nicht zufällig deiner nähe von dem motto
mein schöner anzug wieder läuft ich kein
schneller laufen freunde
ich guck mal automatisch dahin weil da
sonst die fans besteht jetzt habe ich
die da stehen also verzeiht mir dass ich
sehe dich glaubt der stelle weil du kann
einfach nicht mehr
kerstan er läuft einfach durch die ganze
motto ich mach es einfach nicht ich guck
dir das man ja meine bank darum steht
irgendwo angeblich meine karre jedoch
nicht das ist eben der stadt aber wir
müssen trotzdem drauf kommen
gegenwehr schießt auf uns
ich kenne jetzt ein anderes gegen einen
staff match gegen mich machen gar nicht
hoch doch kommen wir denn noch nicht das
was man witze der wieder rein den ebay
nie aber ich will auf die straße ach so
du bist nun gefunden ich draußen leute
das ist mein blog hier bitte lass mich
rein bitte auf die straße davor alle ja
gut ich laufe ich laufe und ich laufe
und ich laufe ich hab mir ein taxi
gerufen und dann dann glauben wir dass
gleich ein richtiger rebell
wie kann man so hart sein wie du älter
man immer tutorial bitte das ist wie in
der bücher ein buch ausleihen ohne
büchern karte kassiert mach ich nicht
dann mama freut sich aber ich freue mich
wer sollte ich nicht hören
so warte ich geh jetzt dass die straße
bei dieser rate tax ich habe normales
auto hier
nein jetzt nicht runter bevor ich konnte
mich überfahren
okay ich habe richtig geil ist alter ich
habe richtigen bleibt stehen die pizza
der eine war kein gegner der anderen
gegner
oh mein gott alter wie schnell die alle
her fand ich habe richtig angst was für
mich direkt hier stets ein sportwagen
man das kann ich aber da sind wir so
sportlich gefasst links finden
ein bagger hat japanerin aber nein
doch ich bin jetzt weg
ich treffe ich weiterfahren
jetzt habe ich zwei stellen dankeschön
damit bringt er nicht noch kein kratzer
wir waren gerade auch den blinker b
start ist das was ich gewillt sind das
die diese sterne fast weg waren
da musst du das ein polizeiwagen ab
unsere karl wenn du auch immer den
polizeiwagen direkt von golo wo keine
polizeiwagen direkt vorbeifährt junge
sind in malibu alter ja jetzt doch
turner hoffen die wohnen in einem von
diesen ja auf jeden
in dem spiel drin wird das auch alles
dreht genau da in dem da da mit dem ja
lassen reinigung von wörter die haar
sprachen an
welches war das hier war das ja das
letzte charlie mich reingelassen als
damit spielen wollte klopf klopf
weihnachtsweisen dass vargas llosa
weihnachtsmann fand das richtig frech
werde oder wenn ich einfach mit dem
pfizer war jetzt ab und würde mit dem
mit dem vers nein nein
dass ich uns geklaut hat mit mit dem ich
uns hierher gebracht habe ohne dass du
hier nicht überleben würden ich warte
auf dich wo bleibst du endlich kommt
gewaltig ich wollte aber wirklich ohne
witz ich wollte nur die ganzen ganz
leicht vor der herfahrt immer aber du
betreibst direkt wieder erstaunlich ich
hab da eine leicht jetzt überfahren und
macht noch diese wegs geste das hast du
davon mikro wie die läuft bei dir jetzt
warte man oder frau kann ich hätte dich
jetzt von vorne kommt von vorne
eigentlich gar direkt ihren deine waffe
hat gelten keine munition wäre es glaube
ich dass menschen was bedeuten die nein
das ist ein dialekt hast dich heute
morgen nicht gewaschen eine flasche bier
holen das bekommen wir nur ein bisschen
barbecue machen es dann wir sind dran
ist sagt mal an wie wertvoll die peilung
ok hatte mein auto steht erstmal
komplett woanders ich mache zwei kurzen
weg punkt zu unserem auto mein gott da
steht hat sich wirklich persönliches
fahrzeug
ach so mein gott es ist einfach es ist
einfach
hatte die karte gleich wie man kritik
arte bisschen weg acht kilometern nur
warte warte pharma kurz nein warte jonas
oder stellt euro p da kommt er schnell
weil die polizei